mein thema ist ja auch eine der
schlimmsten long beach phänomene und
nicht nur herr professor doktor karl
lauterbach ist also ein long beach
phänomen nicht nur er bläst also wir die
backen auf und schlägt auf die panik
trompete und bläst also die tuba der
angst nein es gibt leider gottes auch
ein team lauterbach besonders bei den
gesundheitsministern wie sie heute
getagt haben es steht nicht allein auf
weiter flur genauso starke panische
angst getriebenen machtbewusste töne
stimmen beispielsweise die
gesundheitsminister von baden
württemberg und von bayern an einen
grünen politik und ein csu politiker es
gibt neue vorschläge auf dem tisch von
bayern von baden württemberg von hessen
vielleicht auch von thüringen zum einen
der instrumentenkasten soll
nachgeschärft werden denkt jemand al
capone der macht er den koffer auf man
denkt er sei ein cello drin und es kommt
das maschinengewehr zum vorschein also
der instrumentenkasten ist er ein folter
kasten zweig soll wieder drin sein 3g
masken tragepflicht
abstandsgebot
versammlungsverbote etc das wenn man
alles schaffen und zwar schon am ersten
siebten also am gleichen tag an dem die
evaluation erst vorliegen will das heißt
man arbeitet schon vor ohne die
evaluation zu kennen und sogar der alte
gassenhauer kommt aus der geisterbahn
zurück herr mit der impfpflicht ab 60 am
gleichen tag also an dem österreich die
allgemeine impfpflicht abschafft
erklären uns einige gesundheitsminister
im schönen sachsen anhalt für müssen wir
neu nachdenken über die gesundheits
pflichtpartie über die impfpflicht ab 60
die krachend gescheitert ist herwig hat
heute einen schönen satz gesagt der hat
ja gesagt wir kommen später auch auf ihn
zu sprechen es sei ja ganz ganz schlimm
dass er nur die kohleverstromung wieder
aufnehmen müsse es ging allerdings nicht
anders und er sagte das sei elend aber
notwendig für die deutsche corona
politik geht nur die hälfte dieser
aussage sie es elend aber komplett
unnötig
der vorschlag die union hat ja was die
korona politik zurückblickend betrachtet
auch einiges mitgemacht oder auch selbst
gemacht was man sagen damals war's
regierungspartei hat sich der kurs denn
jetzt innerhalb der partei auch
verändert wissen sie ich sehe da ehrlich
gesagt gar nicht so einen großen
unterschied zwischen den parteien weil
es ist er unterschied zwischen menschen
sie haben in allen parteien die fraktion
angst oder vorsicht wenn sie so nennen
wollen und sie haben auch in allen
parteien leute die das komplett ablehnen
oder sich irgendein irgendeiner weise
damit schwer tun weil es ist eine ganz
menschliche eine ganz persönliche frage
um die es geht und deswegen kann ich da
sozusagen kein und kein unterschied
zwischen diesen beiden lager der union
was die vernunft überwiegt bei der union
das muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen haben
wir sind ja damals mit unserem antrag
eingegangen ein impf register
einzuführen ich habe im übrigen auch
damals diesen abgelehnt weil ich habe
mich dem kubicki antrag angeschlossen
für mich war nichts dergleichen mehr
akzeptabel da haben sie für die
einrichtungs bezogen im finale darf
keine hall of fan auch gegen auf keinen
fall weil ich habe heute auch die
pflegerinnen und pfleger bei mir im büro
zu sitzen die ungeimpft sind und in
gefahr laufen jetzt ihren job zu
verlieren und das halte ich hochgradig
unverantwortlich weil wir nicht den
beleg dafür haben dass eine ungeimpfte
pflegekraft für andere eine größere
gefahr sei enttäuscht dass so wenige
dagegen gestimmt haben und die
einrichtungs beziehungen pflicht so
leicht eine durchgehend wo ich bin
wissen sie ich bin in solchen
schwierigen situationen immer insofern
enttäuscht als dass ich weiß dass viele
meiner kollegen auch gerne ihre meinung
so deutlich kund tun würden es sich aber
nicht getrauen ihn dafür mit der mut
fehlt ja und was müssen sich meine neue
aber stellen sie sich die politische
lage in diesem land vor bei den grünen
ist das tragen einer maske bis heute
noch eine art religion ja das hat nichts
mehr mit dem virus oder mit einer
persönlichen gesundheitsgefahr zu tun ja
so erlebe ich das auch im parlament im
deutschen bundestag und ja das macht
etwas mit menschen viel mehr also sie
sind einerseits die eingelangten
vielleicht machte auch noch viel mehr
mit den leuten die sich diese ganze
debatte quälende debatte jetzt wieder
antun müssen und das kommt ja noch und
ob für den anderen krisen die wir haben
wir haben energiekrise ukraine krieg und
jetzt stellen sich gesundheitsminister
aller länder hin und sagen liebe bürger
ich war schon mal vor wir haben auch mal
eine große debatte demnächst über
allgemeine impfpflicht statt 60
vielleicht kommt die auch wir wollen uns
noch mal die köpfe einschlagen 2g 3g 0
gar nichts herz der im herbst dh das
band das die bürger mit dem start
verbindet wird immer grüner oder auch
weiterhin auf bürger test setzt
eine der maßnahmen aber er riet wenn man
jetzt sogar test bürgerwehr präsentiert
der in die politik noch die bürger
in meinen augen leider nicht mehr in der
art und weise mit mir gehen auch die
meinungsvielfalt völlig und das macht
mich total fertig mariä lichtmess
tätigkeit tun damit sie sich besser
ich weiß nicht ich glaube wir brauchen
tatsächlich irgendwo ein klein bisschen
demokratie reformation eventuell sowas
in der richtung wo ich sage das ist so
ausgerichtet auf
uns deutsche wo man sich ja fast gar
nicht mehr wehren kann was ist denn da
los dass du dich kann ich meinen urlaub
fahren ich muss mich hier völlig
einschränken also ich habe fragen
geht es ihnen sitzen sie heute hier aber
wie kann die politik schaffen konkret
wenn sie jetzt politiker wären was
würden sie tun was möchten sie den
politikern gerne sagen
ihr habt
größtenteils völlig den faden und bezug
zu den leuten verloren meine meinung das
ist richtig weh also wo ich sage was das
leben kostet ein unternehmer mittelstand
oder so ist man weiß es ja was hat es
letztes jahr gekostet hat vorletztes
jahr gekostet was hatte man für einen
scheiß was du nicht wie viel butter
kostet hier war sohn hat mich auch nicht
mehr wusste auch nicht wie viel sprit
kostet jedes jahr als rassistische
aussage was ist das für ein oben und
wollen man muss man muss man muss
natürlich mache jetzt schon lange
politiken im deutschen bundestag und man
muss schon sagen je höher sie in der in
der politischen laufbahn steigen sie
gehen ins kabinett sie werden minister
oder was auch immer desto schwieriger
wird es tatsächlich auch den bezug zur
realität zu bewahren und das war etwas
was mir persönlich von beginn an absolut
wichtig war und dafür muss man manchmal
richtig arbeiten weil sie haben einige
privilegien sie können mit dem mit der
limousine durch die bundeshauptstadt
fahren ja und so weiter und überall wo
sie hinkommen wird in der rote teppich
ausgerollt es ist nicht so dass sie in
eine schule kommen oder eine kita und
sofort die leute oder in ein unternehmen
und die leute ihnen sofort sagen bamm
bamm bamm und das wollte ich ihnen schon
immer mal sagen und das finde ich ja
überhaupt nicht in ordnung nein nein
wird wohl fühlt es wird es man notiert
es wird ein wunderbares bild gezeichnet
und ich muss richtig daran arbeiten dass
man mal die wahrheit gesagt bekommen das
ist auch in ordnung das ist auch absolut
in ordnung weil die menschen haben
natürlich respekt das ist das ist gut so
aber wir müssen wir als politiker müssen
den menschen sagen seid ehrlich zu uns
ja aber das traurige geschichte war es
gut sie haben im zweiten fall angefangen
weil sie haben so getan als wären die
politiker bevor sie politiker wurden
praktische erfahrung gesammelt das ist
aber nicht der fall wenn man den
bundestag mal anschauen der grünen
politiker im bundestag verloren die sind
in jeder freien wirtschaft gearbeitet
wenn sie mal gearbeitet haben parteien
gearbeitet oder in irgendwelchen
parteien organisationen
das ist karriere wir haben also eine
politikerkarriere und das sind menschen
die haben nicht erst die minister waren
kein bezug zur realität wir haben schon
vorher kein bis zur person entsteht weil
sie eben ganz ehrlich wenn sie anfangen
zu arbeiten und haben die lohnabrechnung
und sie sehen mal die abzüge und sehen
was wir machen müssen was ganz anderes
als wenn sie vom studium was ich
politologie geisteswissenschaften direkt
eine vorherige
gegen alle vorteile es gibt doch gehöre
kaufe ich in kauf wenn die tauben auch
nicht missverstehen aber es ist halt so
ich habe einmal geschrieben am liebsten
wäre mir wenn leute fünf jahre erstmal
arbeiten bevor sie sich überhaupt dem im
bundestag nicht so lange trainer einfach
zu sagen so nebenher gesagt man traut
sich nicht das zu sagen haben schneider
die grünen abgelegen ich habe sie so
verstanden auch in den jungs
parteiapparat fraktionen trauen sie
sollen nicht was zu sagen und ganz
ehrlich das parlament lebt davon dass
man debattiert der künstler kann man
dabei spielen und wenn man sich
kommentare haben die nur noch das sagen
was innerhalb der fraktionen genehmigt
wird zu sagen und sprechen abstimmen
dann haben wir natürlich an was sie sagt
und wenn uns davon abhängig sind wenn
sie es nicht machen dann kriegen sie
nämlich nächsten kann ist ein platz
werden so der autor job und weiß nichts
gelernt haben haben wir dann probleme
wir brauchen faire minister und
ausgebildet hat und generell brauchen
die größeren ausschnitt der welt das
geht in die falsche richtung das ist nur
eine halbe wahrheit natürlich ist die
lebenserfahrung entscheidend für die
frage wie ich mein mandat ausfüllen was
ist auch eine charakterliche frage ich
muss doch wissen warum gehe ich in die
politik wenn ich sage ich gehen die
politik um karriere zu machen dann
bekommen sie dann entscheidungen
präsentiert mit denen sie möglicherweise
nicht zufrieden sind aber
dass muss auch jeder für sich selbst
wissen warum er geht und branchen
gehören emilia fester sie ist 320 ich
habe sie jetzt hier auch schon öfter als
thema gab von den grünen jüngste
bundestagsabgeordnete
über die eignung der frau reden weil wir
können hier auch gerade nicht zeigen
dass wer böse aber finden sie mit 23
jahren sollte man schon
bundestagsabgeordnete sein ich würde es
frau fester persönlich nicht empfehlen
weil ich glaube wenn man die ingame 323
mio
naja man muss einfach wissen wenn man
dieses mandat richtig ausfüllen will
dann muss man auch einer 80 jährigen
einen rat geben können und dann muss man
auch hinter seiner meinung stehen können
das habe ich mit 23 sicher hätte ich
sicherlich nicht gekonnt und ich bin
manchmal erstaunt das sage ich auch ganz
ehrlich in dieser runde mit welchem
selbstverständnis mit welcher
hochnäsigkeit menschen aus diese
generation im deutschen bundestag die
opfer die hohe geld in die cdu
eingetreten sind und dann später einen
bundestag also weiterhin mit anfang 20
als studentin in die cdu eingetreten und
bin mit 36 abgeordnete des bundestages
geworden auch noch sehr früh gebe ich
ehrlicherweise zu aber ich habe mich
dafür fit gefühlt ja ich würde zu sein
ich finde wie sie frau gefällt mit 23
das darf weil stellen sie meine erste
erfahrung vorher verfahren wenn jemand
mit 16 lehre macht und hat ihre
berufsausbildung abgeschlossen und geht
dann in die folgen die politik warum
nicht
wir sind leute und praktische erfahrung
viel lieber als leute mit gar keiner
spielt keine rolle spielen wie kann also
erfahrung nur wenn man in gefahr und ich
hatte sich sehr kritisch und das ist
halt sie haben gerade gesagt naja muss
sich wegen karriere absicht in die
politik gehen wir ganz ehrlich wenn ein
politiker nichts bewegen möchte
das ist
ich möchte meine politik was bewegen
wenn du nicht bewegen wollten sollten
die musik kriegen wir steuern jetzt
sehenden auges auf ein corona
winterkrone herbst und das wird auch ein
herbst der debatten müdigkeit werden ein
herbst des stresses ein herbst der angst
um ganz fundamentale dinge ich möchte
noch mal sagen meint seinem job einfach
nicht ernst man überschätzt auch sich
wenn man sagt ich treibe dieses land
jetzt noch einmal in eine solche reise
kontroverse debatten lage wo wir die
anderen schwierigen untergrunds allen
krisen schon haben wir haben eine andere
virusvariante das wissen wir wann
glauben sie die menschen machen es
überhaupt noch mit ich das weil ich es
sind große befürchten dass weniger
menschen es mitmachen werden man sieht
er in berlin schon wir haben keine
masken pflicht in den öffentlichen
nahverkehr 50 würde ich mal sagen
gefühlt an meiner wahrnehmung halten
sich noch dran das waren vor zwei wochen
noch
197 machen es aber treiben und das
werden noch heuer werden also was werden
die gastronomen sagen wenn in lauterbach
ein holodeck und manne lucha wie er sich
nennt auch so ein infantilität manchmal
nennt er sich als manfred manne lucha
der gesundheitsminister aus baden
württemberg sagt wir machen jetzt aber
wieder zweig für veranstaltungen und
weihnachtsfeiern dürft ihr nicht wahr
haben sie angst dass die bürger auf die
barrikaden
ich kann mir das gut vorstellen wenn wir
einige mängel lage haben wo sich mehrere
krisen aufaddieren und zusätzlich wird
wir noch der umgang verboten werden wir
tests aufgenötigt werden wir masken
aufgezogen werden viele sagen ihr könnt
immer ein buckel runterrutschen ich hab
grad ganz andere nöte und dann haben wir
wie gesagt ein ganz ganz großes problem
und dann droht dieser stadt die treusten
seiner bürger zu verlieren wenn wir die
zeit vielleicht noch haben ein letzter
satz ja sehr version an unserer schulen
ist dramatisch das was mir lehrerinnen
und lehrer berichten mit was wir
psychischen beeinträchtigungen gebe es
inzwischen bei kindern und jugendlichen
zu tun haben mit angststörungen ja mit
mit mit sich dem lernen verweigern nicht
mehr in der lage sein zusammen zu sitzen
das ist nicht gut was da angerichtet
wurde und wenn ich heute noch kleine
kinder siebenjährige achtjährige mit
einer fft zwei maske auf dem schulhof
rumlaufen sehe dann kriege ich keine
luft seid euch beiden sozialen medien zu
sehen dass ein ich hoffe es war jetzt
endlich also wieder faktencheck falls
nicht dürfte sehr authentisch also 1 1
ein jahreskalender zum als
willkommensgruß einer weiterführenden
schule oder sah man also offizielles
bild von der schule seien zwei mädchen
die sich mit maske umarmen und sie
hatten auch noch irgendwas wie solche
mit gummi kleider um sie wirklich vor
dem virus zu schützen also mann nötig
ist den leuten schon auf und man
versucht sind das werde ich auch in
lauterbach vor allem vor dass zur neuen
normalität zu machen er sagte es müsse
normalität werden sagte er wörtlich dass
wir alle freiwillig eine maske in
innenräumen tragen also die normalität
besteht darin dass wir alle das selbe
machen aber freiwillig das ist nicht
ja